have big developments in the extradition
case of wikileaks founder julian assange
she faces spying charges here in these
united states and holly williams has the
latest for us holly good morning to you
good morning well after years of legal
wrangling the british government has now
ordered the extradition of julian
assange to the u.s the wikileaks founder
is wanted for violating the espionage
act after publishing hundreds of
thousands of leaked classified u.s
government documents including military
files in 2010. assange's lawyers have
been fighting extradition by arguing
that he's at risk of suicide if he's
incarcerated in an american supermax
prison but the british government said
today that extraditing him would not be
quote oppressive unjust or an abusive
process assange who is an australian
citizen will apparently appeal and now
has 14 days to do so the u.s claims that
by publishing the leaked documents
assange broke the law and endangered
lives his supporters argue that he's a
journalist who exposed wrongdoing by the
u.s and that prosecuting him is a threat
to democracy assange's lawyers claim
that he faces up to 175 years in prison
in the u.s if he's convicted
tony
journalists cover documents they don't
dump them the saga continues holly
williams in london thank you very much